der dritte große punkt ist das reisen
was ist mit denjenigen die sich zum
beispiel entschlossen haben über ostern
nach mallorca zu fliegen und dort ostern
zu verbringen oder urlaub zu machen da
versucht offenbar das kanzleramt jetzt
und andere mit einem trick den deutschen
das reisen zu vermiesen zumindest
eigentlich fast zu verbieten ist ein
quasi verbot denn es geht darum dass man
die dass die instanz also wenn sie auch
gering ist nicht das entscheidende
kriterium sein soll und dass man eine
testpflicht und eine quarantäne
vor allem auch für regionen wo die
inzidenz gering ist durchsetzen will das
könnte bedeuten dass zum beispiel
mallorca am ende
obwohl die incidents niedrig ist eine
gleiche quarantäne zahl bekommt wie zum
beispiel österreich oder andere regionen
wo die inzidenz zahl weit über 100 150
ist und das würde dann bedeuten dass
viele menschen die dorthin wollen die
dorthin reisen wollen am ende nicht
hinfahren können weil wenn sie zurück
nach deutschland kommen zu lange in
quarantäne müssen mehr nachrichten und
breaking news nur bei bate schau dich
hier das nächste video an und vergiss
nicht zu abonnieren